bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans savourgarde ce soir
il y aurait-il de France irréconciliabl
bonsoir Vincent jeambbrin bonsoir merci
d'être notre grand témoin ce soir vous
publé les deux Frances chez Albain
Michel celle du sursaut celle du chaos
et votre histoire on s'en souvient a
marqué le pays lors des émeutes de juin
dernier votre domicile de l'il les rose
dont vous êtes Le Maire les républicains
avait été Atta
incendi attaqué à la voiture bélier on
va y revenir 6 mois après vous prenez la
plume pour faire le diagnostic assez
sombre il faut le dire du pays mais pas
désespéré on en parle tous les deux dans
la deuxième partie tout à l'heure notre
grand débat ce soir un hommage en France
et l'espoir d'une trêve à Gaza on va
revenir sur la cérémonie aux Invalides
pour honorer la mémoire des 42 français
tués par le Hamas le 7 octobre le plus
grand massacre antisémite de notre
siècle a dit le chef de l'État tandis
que sur le terrain dans l'enclave
palestinienne la guerre entre dans son
5e mois on en parle dans un instant avec
mes invités sur ce plateau nos afranchi
ce soir pour terminer l'économie Thomas
Lestavel l'international Isabelle
Lasserre et puis Bourbon Express bien
sûr l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
avec Ala mondingava voilà pour le
sommaire ce soir vous me suivez Vincent
jambrin ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
parti
le 7 le 7 octobre dernier à l'aube
l'indiciible a surgie des profondeurs de
l'histoire les mots du président de la
République ont donc raisonné ce matin
dans la cour des Invalides après l'État
hébreu la France est le premier pays à
organiser un hommage national à ses
victimes du 7 octobre alors que sur le
terrain les combats se concentrent
désormais dans le sud de Gaza sur fond
de projet de trêve bonsoir Éléonore
caroa bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes
député renaissance des Français qui
vivent en Amérique du Sud vous êtes la
vice-présidente de la Commission des
Affaires étrangères à l'Assemblée
nationale bonsoir Alma Dufour ravi de
vous retrouver sur ce plateau député la
France insoumise de scène maritime vous
revenez tout juste d'Égypte avec une
délégation de députés de gauche emmené
par Éric cocrel vous êtes rendu à la
frontière égyptienne juste au post
frontière avec côté égyptien avec avec
avec l'enclave palestinienne bonsoir
David Chemla bonsoir bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes le secrétaire général
européen de jcle grand mouvement
européen pour la paix où sont les voix
de la paix c'est la question qu'on va
vous poser ce soir histoire de l'autre
aux édition Liana Levi vient de
reparaître enfin bonsoir Alexandra
schwarzbro bonsoir merci d'être là vous
êtes la directrice adjointe de la
rédaction de Libération ancienne
correspondante à Jérusalem et puis on a
le plaisir ce soir depuis Jérusalem
d'être avec charlan Derlin bonsoir et
merci beaucoup de nous accompagner dans
cette émission vous avez couvert
évidemment cette région pendant une
vingtaine d'années pour France
Télévision vous venez de publier Israël
l'agonie d'une démocratie au seuil et au
nom du temple réédité en poche voilà
pour les présentations Vincent jeambbray
n'hésitez pas si vous souhaitez réagir
on va commencer d'abord par l'hommage de
ce matin aux invalid les mots les images
c'est dans le recap de Valérie
brchard et bonsoir ma chère Valérie
bonsoir myiam bonsoir à toutes et à tous
ravi de vous retrouver alors cet hommage
oui il n'y avait pas de cercueil myiam
mais 42 visages portés par la garde
républicaine dans la cour d'honneur des
Invalides cet après-midi 42 victimes
françaises ou francoisraélienne tué en
Israël par les terroristes du Hamas lors
de l'attaque du 7 octobre alors 4 mois
jour pour jour après l'assaut le
président de la République a tenu à
rendre hommage à ses victimes et à
travers Emmanuel Macron c'est évidemment
la France entière qui cet après-midi a
aussi saluer la plus grande communauté
juive d'Europe nous sommes 68 millions
de Français en deillé par les attaques
terroristes du 7 octobre
dernier 68
millions mo-s 40 de vie
fauché 42 victimes françaises mais vous
le savez hein cette attaque a entraîné
la mort de presque 1200 personnes
exécutées par bal ou brûl viv dans des
kibuts mais aussi dans un festival de
musique le festival supernova qui a lieu
tous les ans dans la ville de RIM au
matin du 7 octobre de jeune israéliens
venus pour faire la fête venu pour
danser se sont retrouvés prises au piège
un épisode dans cet attentat massif qui
a profondément marqué les esprits il
était
6h et le Hamas lança par
surprise l'attaque massive et
odieuse le plus grand massacre
antisémite de notre
siècle et dans les notes de musique d'un
lieu de fête ont éclaté les tambours de
l'enfer FR et les téléphones de nos
enfants qui jusque-là filmaient les
joies de leur vie sont devenus les
boîtes noires de l'horreur elles nous
entront ces
images un massacre qui a déclenché la
riposte d'Israël contre le Hamas une
guerre toujours en cours que le
président a qualifié de déchirement
parce que ce conflit il fait aussi de
nombreuses victimes civiles
palestiniennes notamment dans la bande
de
Gaza leurs destins ne sont pas les seuls
que le déchirement du Moyen-Orient
continue de broyer dans cette tornade de
souffrance qu'est la
guerre et toutes les vies se valent
inestimable aux yeux de la
France refusant les séparations comme
les divisions refusant l'esprit de mort
de chaos et de clivage que nourrissent
précisément les
terroristes jamais en nous nous ne
laisserons prospérer l'esprit de
revanche voilà pour les temps forts d'un
discours qui était diffusé en simultané
en direct sur la place des otages à tel
àive situé devant le musée des des
beauards et juste à côté du quartier
général he des forces de la défense
israélienne c'est là que se réunissent
les familles des otages depuis le 7
octobre israël compte aujourd'hui encore
136 ressortissants prisonniers du Hamas
et et et parmi eux trois Français dont
les chaises sont restés vides
aujourd'hui ici aux Invalides à Paris
trois otages à qui Emmanuel Macron a
lancé un message la France lutte chaque
jour pour leur libération merci beaucoup
merci Valérie Brochard Alexandre sch je
commence par les les commentateurs
plutôt que les politiques euh il était
il était à la hauteur euh cet hommage
sans sans conteste pourtant certains ont
considéré qu' il avait mis du temps à
venir mais à l'arrivée il a trouvé les
les mots justes oui c'était une
cérémonie très émouvante j'avoue que le
le cadich qui accompagnait ces ces les
photos des des victimes c'était très
très fort très poignant les mots euh du
président ont été également très forts
quand il parle de tornade de souffrance
qui qui secoue qui balaye le le le
proche orient c'est c'est exactement ce
que l'on ressent tous depuis depuis le 7
octobre c'est aussi la première fois que
le président lit le terrorisme qui qu'il
nomme la barbarie et l'antisémitisme
absolument et on l'attendait sur ce
sujet puisqu'on a son son absence à la
manifestation contre l'antisémitisme
avait fait couler beaucoup d'ancre et
fait beaucoup de bruit et et là il a eu
des mots très forts pour évidemment
enfin forcément pour condamner le le
l'antisémitisme et la monté de
l'antisémitisme l'antisémitisme
désinhibé et et ça c'était important
c'était très important 68 millions de
Français ené il s'agit bien de français
Éléonore caroa on a entendu oui mais il
vivait pas en France parfois il parlait
pas la langue française c'était des
Français c'est 42 Français juifs
absolument et il aa dit dans son
discours même s'ils ne sont pas nés en
France même s'ils ne sont pas morts sous
le ciel français ce sont des Français et
c'est un message extrêmement important
et qui raisonne d'autant plus parce que
je suis député des Français de
l'étranger alors certes d'une autre
région du monde mais je pense que c'est
important de se le rappeler on est
français lorsque l'on est ailleurs qu'en
France lorsqu'on a ce rattachement
lorsqu'on a cette nationalité c'était
vraiment un moment très beau un moment à
la hauteur des circonstances qui a
peut-être mis un peu de temps à venir
mais c'était aussi important de prendre
ce recul je pense y compris de ne pas
répondre de ne pas être dans
l'immédiateté de prendre le temps de
faire cet hommage national David Chemla
c'est c'est vrai que il y a pas les
cercueils ça c'est particulier il
fallait quand même les incarner ces 42
français il y avait les portraits ceux
des familles et puis ceux portés par la
Garde Républicaine tant suspendu tant
d'unité aussi vous avez trouvé malgré
les polémiques je pense que c'est
important que la nation se regroupe
derrière le président pour rendre cet
hommage
quels que soi les polémiques et pas le
moment là dans d'yevenenir pendant cet
instant de d'hommage et c'est
importantussi pour les
Israéliens non juifs ou pardon non
français qui en Israël voi que la France
est le premier pays à rendre cet hommage
et reconnaître ce massacre parce qu'il
s'agissait d'un massacre hein il s'agit
pas d'un acte de résistance d'une
organisation c'est une organisation
terroriste comme l'a dit le
président qui a commis ces crimes voilà
donc je crois que c'est très important
que le président les fait Alma du four
on a entendu aussi la position de la
France dans ce discours hein le en même
temps il a aussi des mots pour pour les
morts palestiniens une va une vie vaut
une vie la France n'a pas d'esprit de
refangeche les destins des victimes du
Hamas ne sont pas les seuls il fallait
qu'il soi prononcés ces mots-là bien sûr
bien sûr et déjà je je vous rejoins dans
le sens où effectivement le discours du
président a été dit est vraiment à la
hauteur du moment nous attendons aussi
également vu l'ampleur de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans la bande de Gaza
qu'il y ait un hommage aussi pour les
victimes françaises
françaises Mor à comprenez que N pas pu
il avoir c dommage en même temps av bien
sûr bien sûr c'est pour ça que j'essaie
aussi d'expliquer aux gens qui qui nous
écrivent aussi beaucoup qui sont très
touchés par ce qui se passe à Gaza que
c'est ça va venir mais on espère que ça
viendra et que justement la parole du
président soit incarné véritablement et
qu'on prouve effectivement que la
position de la France c'est que toutes
les vies se valent toutes les vies des
civiles se valent regardez l'invitation
de l'Élysée il s'agissait d'un hommage
aux victimes françaises des attaques
terroristes du 7 octobre Mathilde pano
si est rendu avec Manuel bonpard donc
Mathilde panneau s'est rendu à un
hommage de l'attaque terroriste on est
d'accord on est d'accord sur le fait que
ce ce qui s'est passé ce sont des actes
de terreur la question n nous n'avons
jamais soutenu le Hamas de quelque
manière que ce soit il faut encore le
dire et le redire que ce soit clair
quand on dit que quelqu'un commet un
crime de guerre qui doit être jugé
devant la Cour pénale internationale ce
n'est pas un soutien parce qu'il y a eu
des polémiques qui sont nées sur cette
question du mot terroriste pas
terroriste écoutez moi ce qui me en tout
cas c'est le terme faut ce qu'il faut
comprendre par contre ce que je trouve
inacceptable aujourd'hui c'est justement
l'utilisation de la notion de terrorisme
pour justifier justement que les vies ne
se vaudraient pas c'est ce que François
Holland a fait ce matin ou ce que le
président du CRIF aussi a fait ce matin
en expliquant que des victimes
soi-disant collatérales de la guerre ce
n'était pas pareil que des victimes du
terrorisme ça c'est faux un massacre est
un massacre commis par le Hamas
organisation par
régulre c'est la question
deintentionalité c'est la question d'un
act
délibér on pourra en reparler il y a
évidemment une volonté délibérée de tuer
des civils quand on en arrive à un bilan
aussi catastrophique que 27000 morts
dont 70 % sont des femmes et des enfants
mais pourquoi je comprends pas pourquoi
pourquoi ne pas accepter de proncer le
mot terrorisme
pu pourriez le faire parce que là on l'a
pas entendu et ben si vous voulez c'est
des actes terroristes des actes de
terreur mais mais je pense que le
terrorisme n'est pas le fruit d'une
organisation on peut une armée
régulière vous condamnez votre collègue
qui disait que le Hamas cétait des
mais
on on a condamné monsieur laissez-moi
finir ma phrase il y a eu un communiqué
de presse absolument clair juste après
les propos de ma collègue pour dire que
non on ne considérait pas que le Hamas
avait commis un acte deésist ê plus
clair que ça on a fait un communiqué de
presse n encore une fois on a toujours
condamné les crimes qu'ils ont commis
qui sont des atrocités c'est pour ça
qu'on se sentait évidemment légitime à
participer à cet hommage mais encore une
fois les famill ne le souita pas alors
que mais écoutez si on y était pas allé
quel message on renvoyait que la vie des
civils israéliens et franco-israéliens
n'avait pas de valeur pour nous et le
respect ça aurait été ça aurait été
encore pire donc monsieur là vous êtes
en train de faire de la politique moi je
vous parler du une comité d'accueil les
familles ne le voulaient pas mais il y a
eu un moment de concorde je pense qu'on
peut s'accorder là-dessus et on en a
tous été témoins Charland Derlin pour
terminer sur cet hommage avant d'arriver
sur le sur le terrain la France c'est
vrai on le disait le pays qui a le plus
de ressortissant he tu es dans les
massacres du 7 octobre comment on a
réagi en Israël à téaviv à à cet hommage
a-t-il été très suivi qu'on a pensé la
presse bah écoutez on a eu quelques
images dans l'après-midi sur les trois
grandes chaînes de télévision
israélienne qui font du toute info
durant les après-midis et puis
franchement d'abord quelques confrères
quelques commentateurs ont dit chapeau
la France chapeau Emmanuel Macron vous
avez fait plus que ce que monsieur
netanahou a fait ici pour reconnaître
être la souffrance des victimes de ces
massacres du 7 octobre et puis on est
passé tout de suite à autre chose oui ou
non une trêve ou un cesser le feu
Benjamin netaniaou a pris la parole tout
à l'heure pour annoncer non il n'est pas
question d'accepter la proposition du
ramas nous allons jusqu'à la victoire
totale et les familles des otages
doivent comprendre que seulle la
pression militaire on va y venir on va y
venir avec à cette tentative de de
négocier une trêve et à cette offensive
massive he dans le Sud où une forme de C
de sac là où sont réfugiés tout toutes
les
populations ça ça semble ça semble
vraiment une catastrophe humanitaire en
en en vue mais mais je voudrais vous
entendre sur les trois otages français
il faut donner leur nom orad yalomi Auer
Calderon Orion Hernandez dont on a
aucune preuve de vie
aujourd'hui est-ce que est-ce que les
pressions diplomatiques sont sont
suffisantes est-ce que il se passent des
choses
les concernants ben écoutez non il ne se
passe rien et d'ailleurs selon l'armée
israélienne sur les 136 otages qui se
trouvent à Gaza au moins une trentaine
sont considéré comme déjà morts et la
question se pose sur une vingtaine
d'autres alors qui est vivant qui ne
l'est pas on ne sait même pas si ceux
des otages qui ont besoin de traitements
médicaux ont reçu les médicaments ça
avait été d'ailleurs une initiative
française on ne sait pas si c'est arrivé
s'ils les ont reçu vous savez vous avez
affaire à au Hamas qui est un mouvement
fondamentaliste djihadiste qui n'a pas
du tout un objectif qui ressemble
politique ils ont effectivement
l'intention d'aller jusqu'au bout je
reviens vers vous tout à l'heure Charl
Derlin je vais vous faire écouter Morane
Yanaï c'est une ancienne otage du Hamas
capturée lors de la rêve partie elle
était à l'Assemblée hier pour la
projection d'un documentaire et Madame
la Députée vous réagirez sur nos otages
juste
après
elle a survécu à 54 jours de captivité
et elle continue à se battre elle mérite
de commencer à prendre soin d'elle et
cela ne peut arriver que si les 136
otages sont
libérés mon cœur est toujours à Gaza je
ne suis toujours pas revenu chez moi
jusqu'à ce que tout le monde soit rentré
ma vie est arrêtée j'ai une mission et
c'est de faire tout ce que je peux pour
ramener mes amis à la
maison alors Richard il ne se passe rien
concernant les les otages et et nos
trois otages en
particulier que fait la France pour
obtenir leur libération alors que fait
la France précisément dans dans cette
situation qui est extrêmement
délicate nous ne le savons pas mais nous
savons en revanche précisément qu'il y a
des négociations qui sont en cours des
discussions qui sont en cours qu'il y a
une pression qui a été exercée on sait
aussi que la France s'est rendu que ce
soit par le Président de la République
ou par les différents ministres
immédiatement euh au au Proche Orient on
sait que le ministre des Affaires
étrangères y est en ce moment où il va
très prochainement donc on sait que la
France est présente et que la France
contrairement à d'autres pays a dès le
début envoyé un message d'équilibre et
je pense que dans le contexte dans
lequel nous sommes dans le brouillard
absolu et dans la tragédie qui est en
train de se jouer le fait d'avoir cette
voie-là c'est déjà quelque chose
d'extrêmement important alors justement
les combats font toujours rage à Gaza
avec un nouvel objectif pour tsal je le
disais Rafa la ville la plus au sud de
l'enclave à la frontière égyptienne
aucun signe d'acalmie donc même si une
trêve est en cours de négociation
regardez c'est signé ma
fr debout au milieu des décombres de son
immeuble raled als soufi tout comme
d'autres Palestiniens de Rafa est venu
constater les dégâts causés par la
nouvelle frappe israélienne de la nuit
j'étais chez moi quand j'ai entendu les
bombardements mais quand j'ai ouvert ma
porte des éclat et des PIR m frapp à la
tête Israël Gaza 4 mois de conflit et à
nouveau l'espoir d'une trêve en échange
d'un certain nombre de prisonniers
palestiniens le Hamas se dit prêt à
libérer des otages initiative supervisée
par l'Égypte et le Qatar encouragé par
Anthony blinken le secrétaire d'État
américain en visite dans la région pour
faire avancer la
négociation il y a beaucoup de travail à
faire faisons tout pour y
parvenir mais la guerre est loin d'être
terminée et au plus près de ces troupes
le ministre israélien de la Défense lui
promet qu'il ne s'arrêtera pas là avec
en ligne de mire toujours le même
objectif éradiquer l'organisation
terroriste tout terroriste qui se cache
à Rafa doit savoir que sa fin sera la
même qu'à canyunis ou n'importe où
ailleurs dans la bande de Gaza se rendre
ou mourir il n'y a pas de troisième
option
une stratégie qui fracture encore
davantage la société israélienne dans
les rues de Tel Aviv maintenant Scand
des centaines de manifestants israéliens
qui dénoncent cet impasse et réclam un
cess le feu le seul moyen est de
conclure un accord c'est ce qui signifie
être courageux et leader et je continue
de penser qu'après cela nous aurons le
temps de nous occuper du Hamas mais il
faut d'abord s'occuper des
quant à l'extrême droite sa priorité
c'est la reconquête avec un mot d'ordre
recoloniser Gaza la solution de paix à
deux états n'a jamais semblé aussi loin
Alexandra je pour déjà comprendre ce qui
se passe avec cet objectif nouveau de
Rafa Israël est capable d'une telle
offensive au sol sachant qu'il y a un
million et demi de réfugiés palestiniens
au sud de l'enclave je pense que il faut
les prendre au mot ah je pense qu'on
peut les prendre au mot les dirigeants
israéliens Benyamin netaniaahou en tête
euh euh veulent euh veulent avoir au
moins la tête du dirigeant militaire de
la branche militaire du du Hamas Yaya
sin noir et et tant qu'il ne l'aura pas
je pense qu'ils continueront qu'ils
essaieront parce que c'est c'est leur
but de guerre si vous voulez c'est
d'avoir la tête du du chef militaire du
Hamas et d'éradiquer comme ils disent
tout ce qui peut constituer la moindre
infrastructure du Hamas pour que ce ne
soit plus possible sans le problème
c'est que voilà là ils sont en train de
susciter des tas de
vocation et puis de vocation de de
d'enfants qui qui voudront peut-être un
jour se venger et le problème aussi
c'est que Benjamin netanahou tant qu'il
y a la guerre il reste en place donc on
voit bien et votre reportage le montre
bien toutes ces toutes ces intentions
contraires entre l'extrême droite qui
veut reconquérir absolument Gaza entre
les Israéliens qui sont partagés entre
ceux qui veulent absolument que cela ne
se produise plus jamais et qui veulent
aller jusqu'au bout au niveau militaire
ceux qui veulent incesser le feu pour
libérer il en a parce qu'il faut le dire
aussi hein la société israëenne est
dévisée il y a des manifestations pour
ce trêve pour inesser le feu et aussi le
Hamas le Hamas qui ne qui qui qui ne
veut pas lâcher l'affaire c'est-à-dire
que le Hamas a publié un communiqué là
ces dernières heures demandant à ce que
la reconstruction ce soit lui ce soit le
mouvement qui pilote la construction de
Gaza ce qui est absolument
impensable donc si vous voulez là il y a
une espèce de de de de d'impasse absolu
et en même temps tout le monde sait que
il va falloir qu'il y ait quelque chose
qui sorte de tout ça ça c'est le seul
petite lueur d'espoir c'est qu'inken est
sur place pour je ne sais plus la
combientième fois là il passe sa vie au
Moyen-Orient al madifour vous vous
revenez d'Égypte et vous êtes allé au
post-frontière vous avez rencontré les
humanitaires la situation est absolument
catastrophique mais on on narrive pas à
comprendre pourquoi l'Égypte ne l'ouvre
pas au civils cette frontière pourquoi
il y a des
blindés à ce poste là pour pour des gens
qu'on pourrait au moins temporairement
sauver alors déjà la situation n'est pas
que catastrophique je rappelle que la
Cour internationale de Justice qualifie
ce qui est en train de passer de se
passer de risqu potentiel de génocide
vous l'avez dit 1,3 millions de
personnes qui sont concentrées dans une
ville qui est faite pour accueillir
200000 personnes les hum San itire les
médecins français qu'on a rencontré nous
ont parlé d'une situation mais
inimaginable inimaginable entre les
morts direct des bombardements les morts
de de d'accidents dans les hôpitaux il
n'y a plus d'eau potable ce n'est pas
des victimes collatéral quand on affâme
volontairement une population quand on
ne laisse pas entrer quand on coupe le
jus quand il y a plus d'eau courante
quand il y a plus des bouteilles d'eau
qui n'y a quasiment que des rations qui
suffisent pas à la survie et qu'on a
500000 personnes qui sont menacées de
faminees ce n'est plus ce qu'on appelle
des victimes collatérales j'étais dans
l'entrepôt du Croissant Rouge égyptien
j'ai vu tous les tous les objets
humanitaires qui ont été refusés mais il
faut que je dise moi je suis là pour
témoigner de ce que j'ai vu
refus israélienne parce qu'il pouvait
soit-disant être utilisé par le Hamas il
y avait des jeux pour enfants il y avait
des filtres à eau il y avait des
bouteilles d'oxygène et il y avait
certains kits médicaux d'urgence envoyés
par la France alors la question si
l'Égypte n'ouvre pas sa frontière pour
temporairement c'est qu'on n'est pas
certain et vous l'avez dit des
intentions réelles du gouvernement
israélien son objectif c'est quoi
éliminer la tête du Hamas et juste
éliminer le Hamas ou c'est effectivement
comme l'ail qui est au gouvernement
l'ail d'extrême droite le dit et le
redit depuis des semaines reprendre le
contrôle de la bande de Gaza et la vider
de sa population parce qu'il y a des
tractations il y a des tentatives de ça
et il y a aussi un membre du Liou qui
est par
N qui s rendu à cette conférence de
l'extrême droite où il disait nous
allons reprendre contrôle de Gaza
benamin netan a parl pour vous c'est
d'abord la faute des Israéliens si les
Égyptiens n'ouvrent pas bah écoutez mais
attendez on prend pas les excusez-moi on
prend pas l'histoire un livre au dernier
chapitre d'accord ce qui s'est passé le
7 octobre je vais reprendre les mots de
monsieur bourlange qui est modamme qu'on
pourra pas taxer de toutes les attaques
qu'on nous attribu à nous si les actes
du Hamas n'ont pas d'excuse ils ont des
causes d'accord tout ce qui s'est passé
n'oublions pas qu'en sis Jordanie qui
n'est pas contrôlé par le Hamas la
colonisation continue depuis des
annéesityp non mais du coup ce que je
veux dire c'est que si l'Égypte est-ce
que c'est à
l'Égypte millions de
Gazaoui parce que Israël voudrait vider
la bande de Gaza de sa population c'est
ça la question c'est la crainte d'une
forme de nettoyage ethnique qui ferait
que que les les Gazaoui ne reviendrai
pas après c'est ça l'argument David
c'est l'argument de l' bien sûr on va
pas refaire toute l'histoire parce queon
naura pas de assez de temps dans
l'émission euh l'attaque du 7 octobre
n'était pas un acte de défense ou un
acte de résistance c'est un acte
terroriste et la majorité laacn
actuellement qui est au pouvoir depuis
suite aux dernières élections n'est plus
aujourd'hui une majorité s'il y avait
des élections ce gouvernement
n'existerait pas vous le savez très bien
tous les sondages NRE que natanahou
aujourd'hui n'est soutenu que par 20 %
de sa population et les extrémistes de
droite qui appellent un retour euh à la
colonisation sont minoritaires ils sont
importants ils sont 10 15 % peut-être au
maximum mais personne dans le pays
suivra le projet de aller se réinstaller
à Gaza après le massacre qui ont lieu
aucun israélien ne voudra vivre à côté
d'un Palestinien parce que ils ont vécu
un massacre ils vont pas vivre à côté
des Palestiniens ça c'est une sécurité
alors ça c'est une chose deuxièmement
deuxièmement la aujourd'hui les la les
provisions toute l'aide humanitaire qui
rentre à Gaza on le sait le Hamas met la
main dessus pour la redistribuer et en
garde une partie pour elle-même et pour
ses forces c'est aussi une réalité il y
a tout un débat pour savoir comment
permettre à ce que vraiment cette aide
arrive aux populations qu' on en besoin
troisième problème c'est le problème
politique problème politique aujourd'hui
euh dans votre commentaire vous disiez
que la solution de états est plus loin
que jamais je pense que au contraire la
solution de états est revenu aujourd'hui
au centre des préoccupations
internationales ce qui n'était pas le
cas depuis des anné alors expliquez-nous
parce que quand on suit la situation on
se dit qu'on on va vers laabî et c'est
ces moments-là qui font que le politique
peut enfin agir et et se faire entendre
vraiment dans les fait on se rend compte
qu'on peut pas maintenir ce problème à
côté et vivre comme si de rien éétait et
vivre avec la colonisation qui continue
dans les territoires et et un espèce de
statut quo qui en est vraiment pas un on
s'est rendu compte que ce n'est pas
possible que les Palestiniens ont besoin
et d'un état et et quand vous dites on
c'est qui parce que les voix de la paix
malheureusement
il des plans depu on sait com
résoudreème sur plan des plans on sait
les partag les échanges de territoire
céit pas un problème de plan on sait
qu'il y a les moyens dans la communauté
internationale pour investir et
développer toute cette région il faut
une volonté politique de côtés on manque
de quoi de volonté politique ou d'homme
pour la porter il faut des hommes pour
les porter mais des solutions existent
mais maintenant il faut passer la crise
actuelle sortir de Israël vous savez la
population vit encore dans la stup de
l'événement du 7 octobre pour pouvoir
passer au politiqu il y a la
problématique des otages qui qui pousse
la population dans la rue et savoir
comment trouver une solution pour PIR
retourner pour la population israélienne
qui a quitté toutes les villages et les
kibuts qui é à la frontière de Gaza il
demande voir une garantie de sécurité
pour y retourner quand on écoute le
ministre de la Défense Jof Galand dire
que voilà il va y avoir une offensive
militaire d'ampleur Arafa là où toutes
les populations palestiniennes sont
massées et qu'en même temps on parle de
trêve de négociation d'une trêve en
gros les otages libérés contre arrêt des
combats un mois 2 mois tout ça sous la
pression américaine on est dans deux
dans deux logiques mais antagonistes
comment c'est possible de faire les deux
en même temps ce qu'on voit c'est que ça
fait 4 mois que la guerre la guerre dure
a éclaté à nouveau sur un territoire qui
vit cette tragédie depuis 1947 donc on
voit que ça fait 4 mois qu'il y a eu des
évolutions il y a eu des tentatives de
trêve il y a eu C à cette prve
aujourd'hui à l'heure de l'attaque sur
sur on doit y croire on doit y croire et
je pense que lorsque vous citiez tout à
l'heure monsieur bourlange j'urité
c'était l'archevêque Vesco d'Alger mais
sur les causes c'est important de
s'interroger sur les causes évidemment
et elles sont multiples mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut surtout
s'interroger sur les issues possibles
les solutions possibles et le rôle que
nous pouvons jouer en tant que
communauté internationale et dans ce
sens-là je pense que la France encore
une fois il faut le dire il faut en être
fier d'une certaine façon même si nous
devons faire davantage davantage est une
puissance d'équilibre doit l'être et
l'Union européenne encore davantage
alors lorsqu'on regarde solution à deux
états on a jamais étaé aussi loin mais
aussi aussi près parce que il n'y a pas
le choix et vous parliez tout à l'heure
de la responsabilité d'Israël mais il y
a aussi la responsabilité des autres
pays du monde arabe qui finalement ont
aussi une part de responsabilité et on
sait aussi qu'il y a l'Iran derrière
donc c'est évidemment beaucoup plus
compliqué même si ce n'est pas la la
seule cause et il y a aussi les
États-Unis les États-Unis qui se sont
désengagés notamment sous Trump et qui
aujourd'hui payent très cher le prix de
leur désengagement alors là ils sont là
les Américains pour l'instant jusqu'à
l'élection américaine ils ont la clé
de la communauté internationale s'était
totalement désengagée du conflit
israë-palestinien les Palestiniens
étaient passés par pertes et profit au
bénéfice des accords d'Abraham entre
l'Arabie Saoudite et Israël enfin
l'Arabie Saoudite et d'autres leaders
arabes et je crois que cette tragédie a
fait prendre conscience à tout le monde
comme le dit tren David Chemla que l'on
ne peut pas mettre sous le tapis le
conflit israpalestinien et ce que vivent
les Palestiniens de Gaza et de s
Jordanie et ce qui pe parne ne comprend
pourquoi de l'extérieur netanah est
toujours au pouvoir on nentend aucune
voix de la paix en Israël cé
palestinien mais pour l'instant on est
dans une crise gravissime qui n'est pas
encore terminée et qui va faire encore
malheureusement de très nombreux morts
et blessés je crois que les les leaders
vous avez parlé des leaders des pays
arabes ils sont très importants jusqu'à
présent il s totalement moqué des
palestinens le Qatar le l'Arabie
Saoudite tous les tous les mais oui
l'Arabie Saoudie très important et ils
ont compris Arabie saite et ils ont
compris ces leaders là que pour leur
population que leur population n'était
pas insensible au sort des Palestiniens
et qui ne pouvaent pas se permettre de
de balayer ce sujet donc je crois en
effet comme comme vous le dites très
bien que on on est dans un drame absolu
aujourd'hui demain aussi sans doute mais
après-demain peut-être tout tout le
monde a conscience que maintenant il
faut enfin faire quelque chose c'est le
seul petit c'est maintenant jamais c'est
ça m' du four et je vous donz le mot de
la fin mais il faut il faut conclure
viment vraiment pour finir la position
d'équilibre de la France n'est pas
suffisante étant donné l'ampleur de ce
qui est en cours un risque de génocide
un risque de génocide si on transpose
d'illeurs la Haute cour de jus voilà de
la Cour internationale de justice de l'
si on transposait ce conflit ailleurs
dans on se j'ai dit risque de génocide
on se POS
on se poserait la question de sanction
économique et diplomatique nous ça fait
plusieurs mois qu'on propose au
Parlement européen le groupe de la
France insoumise au moins l'embargo sur
la vente d'armes à Israël de la part des
pays européens c'est quelque chose qu'on
arrive même pas à obtenir ensuite les
États-Unis ils vont ils se déplacent
souvent ils font pression en tout cas en
attendant ce qu'ils ont fait au Conseil
de sécurité de l'ONU c'est mettre leur
vet plusieurs fois à toute intervention
de la communauté internationale dans ce
conflit et désarmé ça n pas de sens dans
cette affaire il y a des
terroristoc a VI CIV les dé vous les
déplorez vraiment 27000 morts ça pas
l'air de vous toucher beaucoup monsieur
je
suisol vous demandez des une démocratie
parce que en face les terroristes qui
veulent c'est abattre toutes les
démocraties de l'Occident et je crois
maisut faut juste avir le courage de le
dire on a en face de nous des gens qui
sont dans une logique de dihad vous
disiez très bien et le dihad c'est la
destruction de l'autre et
allez on va terminer ce débat je vous
donne le mot de la fin d' on
s'interrogait sur les homm de Pai vous
vous êtes à la tête d'un mouvement
ancien pour la paix la paix maintenant
vous les voyez on pense peut-être à
bargouti côté palestinien Mohamed Darlan
qui en Israël benigandz qui sont les
hommes de paix aujourd'hui sur qui on
peut se projeter ou les femmes les FEM
le monsieur Jean disait israël est une
démocratie les élections auront lieu
certainement dans les mois à venir dans
l'année 24 parce que Nathan n'est plus
n'a plus aujourd'hui un un support au
sein de la population un sondage récent
fait en Israël montre que plus de 50 %
soutiennent l'initiative qu'on appelle
blanc Biden ou doctrine Biden dans
lequel il y aurait par étape un retour
au processus de paix sur la base de deux
états je crois que la population
souhaite une solution mais souhaite
aussi la sécurité la garantie cette
sécurité bon on s'arrête là on pourrait
continuer très longtemps merci beaucoup
merci d'être venu débattre sur le
plateau de LCP vous restez avec moi
Vincent jambrin dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties pr nos affranchi
vous les voyez ils sont fin prêt ce soir
l'économie Thomas Lestavel qui
s'interroge sur le groupe Athos en
pleine tourmente international Isabelle
lasser un émissaire américain pro Trump
à Moscou ça mérite une explication et
puis le menu de Bourbon Express ce soir
els mondingava je vous parle des
questions au gouvernement et je vous en
parle plutôt deux fois qu'une myiam à
tout à l'heure les amis mais d'abord on
va plonger dans votre L
quels sont ces deux Frances que vous
décrivez celle du chaos celle du sursaut
chez Alber Michel et puis que vous
est-il arrivé ça mérite de revenir sur
les faits là il est rose les émeutes de
juin dernier regardez c'est dans
l'invitation de Marco
[Musique]
Pomier si on vous invite Vincent
jambrin c'est parce que le Parlement
veut mieux protéger les élus locaux
jusqu'à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et 100000
€ d'amende en cas de violence une
nouvelle loi pour en finir avec ses
agressions plus de 2200 en
2022 je pense au maire de Lael rose
Vincent janbrin et je pense à sa femme
et à ses deux enfants dont le domicile
personnel a fait l'objet d'une attaque
particulièrement choquante qui mieux que
vous Vincent jeanbrin pour incarner ses
élus en première ligne contre les
violences maèire de l'il les rose depuis
près de 10 ans vous avez cru tout perdre
au début de l'été juillet 2023 les
émeutes embrassent le pays après la mort
du jeune
alors que vous veillez sur votre mairie
barricadée entourée de barbelé votre
domicile est pris pour cible une voiture
bélier en feu projeté contre votre
maison nous avons vu le vrai visage des
hémetiers celui d'assassin ils ont
redirigé leur haine en recourant à un
acte
ignoble ils ont voulu assassiner ma
femme et nos de jeunes enfants dans leur
sommeil et les Brû vif en tentant notre
maison entre les tirs de mortier votre
femme et vos deux jeunes enfants
s'échapperont par le jardin votre épouse
sera gravement blessé au genoux cette
nuit d'horreur vous la rbobiné dans
votre livre l'occasion aussi de revenir
sur votre engagement politique et de
livrer votre vision du pays il y a en
réalité deux Frances l'une qui génère du
désordre l'autre à bout de souffle qui
tente de résister et de sauver ce qui
peut encore l'être 6 mois après les
émeutes les bresses de la colère couvent
toujours
ent vous pointez du doit la démission de
l'État face à une crise de l'autorité
malgré une série de mesures répressiv
annonc réponse pénale plus ferme
encadrement des jeunes délinquants par
des militaires stage de responsabilité
parentale malgré aussi le slogan de
fermeté du nouveau Premier
ministre nto
[Applaudissements]
tuautorité politique applaudit mais
alors Vincent jeambbrin que faire pour
réconcilier ces deux
Frances alors quelle réponse àorter je
suis pas sûr qu'on puisse réconcilier
les deux Frances dont je parle dans le
livre puisque dans le livre je parle de
la France du sursaut celle qui a envie
de défendre notre République notre
modèle de liberté d'égalité de
fraternité et en face je je montre du
doigt la France du chaos c'est-à-dire
celles et ceux qui veulent détruire
notre République notre modèle social et
notre vivre ensemble mais vous n'êtes
pas résigné parce que celle qui
s'attaque à nos valeurs à notre modèle
vous souhaitez aussi quand même dans ce
livre quelque
part la
ramener pour vous il y a une partie de
la France qui a déjà fait sescessions
c'est trop tard il y a une toute petite
minorité qui qui aujourd'hui attaque et
qui attaque de deux façons il y a ceux
qui nous attaquent de manière physique
les caïdes les gangs les mafias qui
gangrainent nos quartiers notamment les
quartiers populaires et qui sont à
l'origine de ce qu'on a vécu cet été
avec les émeutes puisque ce sont eux qui
tien prisonniers je crois qu'il y a pas
d'autres mot on parlait de terroriste
tout à l'heure qui terrorise 5 à 6
millions de Français qui vivent dans ces
quartiers où en vérité plus personne n'a
envie d'aller vivre et cela ils
combattent tout ce qui fait notre
République et nous devons avoir le
courage de dire qu'ils existent qu'ils
sont là et que nous devons les combattre
il s'agit pas de se réconcilier avec les
gangs et les mafias mais c'est pour
mieux se réconcilier avec ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont en désamour désamour
avec la République parce qu'ils se
disent la République nous abandonne je
disais qu'il y avait deux modèles il y a
ceux qui nous attaquent physiquement et
ceux qui nous attaque idéologiquement et
là-dessus j'en parle aussi dans le livre
il y a ce que j'appelle les séparatistes
ceux qui veulent imposer une autre
idéologie un autre dogme à notre républi
et enfin plutôt combattre not r il y a
évidemment les islamismes radicaux et
puis vous avez aussi je crois des des
personnes qui veulent un autre modèle
social il y a il y a des wistes
extrémistes il y a des black blocks il y
a des anarchistes c'est pas uniquement
le fait religieux et donc non le but
n'est pas de réconcilier ces deux Fran
là par contre c'est d'inviter tous les
Français à dire choisissez le camp du
sursaut parce qu'après ce que j'ai vécu
C été après ce que nous avons vécu cet
été on se dit que ne rien faire sans
désintéresser c'est déjà laisser gagner
la France du chaos vous êtes petit fils
d'immigré italien père chauffeur livreur
mère femme au foyer vous avez grandi on
l'a dit dans la cité des tours marrons
vous la connaissez bien cette barre de
H&M de la rose dont vous êtes devenu le
maire aujourd'hui c'est pas banal comme
itinéire en 20 ans ce quartier a
beaucoup changé en mal comment qu'est-ce
qui s'est dégradé qu'est-ce qui s'est
défait précisé il a beaucoup de choses
qui sont des fait moi je dois énormément
à la République
euh enfant qui grandit dans les bar àlm
avec les parents que vous venezit
déécrire qui qui nous ont aidé mais avec
les moyens qui étaient les leurs et
c'est notamment l'école de la République
la promesse républicaine qui fait que je
peux devenir maèire de la ville qui m'a
vu grandir cette république là je l'aime
tellement que j'ai longtemps cru qu'elle
était invincible qu'elle allait de soi
qu'elle était quelque chose qui était
indétronnable inattaquable et ce que je
décou couvre dans mon mandat de mer j'en
parle un peu dans le livre ce que je
découvre si tristement cet été c'est
qu'en fait la République elle va pas de
soi c'est une richesse extraordinaire
mais que c'est une richesse fragile et
que je j'ose le dire elle est même
mortelle et que si on ne la défend pas
face à ce que j'appelle la France du
chaos alors elle peut disparaître et
dans ces quartiers ce qui a disparu
c'est tout ce qui est la promesse
républicaine l'école qui vous émancipe
les commerces qui vous aident à vivre et
apporte du travail le soin la santé bref
tout ce qui fait la promesse de la
République qui vous tire vers le haut a
disparu moi quand j'étais gamin je je le
dis aussi l'ascenseur social il était
déjà cassé mais il y avait les escaliers
si on s'en en voulait un petit peu et on
est toute une génération à s'en être
sorti euh aujourd'hui vous pouvez même
pas prendre l'escalier parce que vous
traversez un H d'immeuble en fumé avec
des des types qui pardon mais mais
prennent en otage tous les habitants de
l'immeuble avec des Kalashnikovs c'est
une vraie réalité aujourd'hui vous
étudiez tranquillement dans votre
chambre et il y a une balle perdue qui
vous tue c'est ça la réalité C N
d'ailleurs pendant les émeutes vous avez
des mot fort hein dans le livre vous
parlez d'un climat insurrectionnel quasi
guerre civile la mort de Neelle pour
vous on comprend très bien qu'elle n'est
qu'un prétexte pour s'en prendre à la
République on va y venir mais j'aimerais
que vous écoutiez la lecture qu'a fait
Emmanuel Macron de ce qui s'est passé en
juin dernier ce qu'on a appelé les
ameutes urbaines même si c'est un mot
que vous peut-être vous récusez vous me
direz regardez c'était lors de la
dernière conférence de presse
présidentielle d'abord elles sont
intervenues fin
juin c'était beaucoup de très je qui
étai dans les rues et c'était des jeunes
c'est une erreur qu'on a
commise qui était souvent sans école
depuis le mois
d'avril réforme du brevet réforme du
baccalauréat l'organisation commune le
système tel qui marche plus de classe
loisiveté les vieux précept parfois
disent beaucoup c'était des jeunes qui
ont pas la chance d'avoir des familles
qui les emmènent à la mer à la montagne
qui justement ont pas assez accès à la
culture au sport
il s'ennuyait il s'ennuyait vous êtes en
complète opposition avec cette lecture
c'est pas ce que j'ai vécu président de
la République décrit les rapports qui
sont remontés de toute la France moi je
je contenteris je me contenterai de
témoigner sur ce qu'on a vécu à lail
rose pendant ces nuits d'émeutes on a eu
une organisation qui s'est attaqué à la
République et j'insiste sur ce mot
d'organisation il y avait un cœur de
cortège qui était extrêmement organisé
avec avec des éclaireurs à scooter qui
ait repéré où était la police avec des
des des l'infanterie qui était là armée
de avec des armes aussi préparé de hache
de piolet de barre de fer vous aviez la
la la camionnette don les plaques
avaient été masqué qui apportaient les
mortiers les cocktails Molotof bref la
logistique vous aviez les tirailleurs
avec leur mortiers préparés gantés les
gants scotchés pour qu'il y ait pas
d'ADN pas de trace de poudre tous la
même cagoule tous les mêmes parapluies
pour se protéger et cetera enfin c'était
extrême organisé c'est une Guera en fait
et c'était une Guera insurrectionnelle
qui attaquait les symboles de la
République alors en marche de ça il y a
eu ce que j'appelle les que de comètes
il y a eu des gamins qui sont sortis de
leur tour et qui sont venus regarder ce
qui se passe qu' on vu de filmer qui
sont évidemment qui a eu ça et
d'ailleurs comme c'était les queue de
comèt c'est ceux qui étaient un peu plus
loin c'est ceux que la police à
l'échelle nationale a réussi à attraper
parce que moi la rose personne n'a été
attrapé personne pas tropamation pour le
moment mais parce que personne il pas eu
une personne interpellée pas une parce
que que pour interpeller quelqu'un à un
moment donné il faut lui mettre les
mains dessus et quand vous n'avez pas
d'effectif sur le terrain pour pouvoir
le faire ça ne marche pas je ne sais pas
ce qui s'est passé dans toutes les
villes je préends pas le savoir et que
il y a des gamins qui qui étaient qui
mais c'est pas ce que vous avez V chez
mais chez nous il y a eu une attaque de
la République une attaque en règle avec
un état qui a failli parce que ça c'est
dans le livre aussi vous êtes très très
dur avec l'État un état qui n'était plus
là vous vous dites que l'État a
démissionné quelques jours avant même
vous vous êtes battu pour obtenir des
munitions supplémentaires pour pour les
policiers s'il y avait pas eu la BRI
finalement la mairie n'aurait pas pu
être
protégée vous pensez que en gros l'État
se défausse sur sur les maires qui sont
trop seuls en première
ligne faut imaginer ce que ça fait pour
nos policiers municipaux qui sont des
défenseurs de la République et de ce
qu'elle a de plus beau et je dirais même
des défenseurs de l'État et qui ont tenu
seul la défense de la ville des rues de
la ville des bâtiments municipaux moi
j'aurais plus de Maie s'ils avaient pas
défendu à leur risque et péril l'Hôtel
de Ville imaginez ce que ça fait pour
eux d'appeler le 17 et que plus personne
ne répondent et quand je dis ça c'est
pas faire offense aux policiers
nationaux qui étaient eux-mêmes
totalement débordés et qui défendaient
avec beaucoup de courage le commissariat
de police nationale qui qui est sur la
ville c'est faire offense à personne
mais simplement faire un constat et
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait le livre
pour que personne ne l'oublie ce soir-là
la République ne répondait plus parce
que nous n'étions pas dimensionnés pour
réagir à ça et on n'est pas dimensionné
parce que pendant trop longtemps on a
nié cette réalité on a nié qu'il y a des
adversaires qu'il y a des ennemis qui
aujourd'hui sont prêts à s'attaquer à la
République les ennemis de l'intérieur
vous leur consacré un chapitre c'est
aussi un livre d'un père de famille qui
a eu très très peur il faut le dire et
on le sent dans dans l'écriture pour les
siens même plus que ça qui s'est aussi
senti coupable vous racontez les heures
terribles lorsque votre épouse vous
appelle et vous dit ils veulent nous
tuer il y a le feu dans le jardin c'est
une forme de thérapie ce livre aussi
est-ce que est-ce que cette épreuve pour
votre famille est aujourd'hui derrière
vous l'épreuve elle est elle est en
partie derrière et en même temps
maintenant elle fait partie de notre
socle de quelque chose qui nous a forgé
qui fait qu'on est plus fort plus dur
aujourd'hui plus résistant peut-être et
devant vous beaucoup plus motivé que
jamais parce que parce que tout ça peut
pas être arrivé pour rien et bien sûr
que quand je prends la plume pour écrire
ce livre après beaucoup d'hésitations
d'ailleurs je fais d'abord pour moi pour
pour pour jeter sur le papier tout ce
que je ressens euh avant même de savoir
que ça pourrait être un livre je le fais
parce que je veux pas qu'on oublie parce
que je veux pas qu'on nous dise que
c'était euh juste des violences urbaines
de plus ces émeutes elles avaient un un
signe tout autre auquel est venu se
rajouter plein d'autres choses les
pillages de supermarchés ou de centres
commerciaux évidemment c'est venu à côté
c'est ces petites violences urbaines
mais à l'intérieur de ça la République a
été testée et je je crois qu'il faut
avoir le courage de dire que on a perdu
cette première manche perdu on a perdu
cette aré net quand même et justement
c'est très ét vous avez des des réponses
à cette sou personement et
personnellement je pense que des gang de
la drogue qui aurait qui serait
intervenu parce que en tout cas c'était
sacrément bien organisé c'était
sacrément bien organisé et je vais vous
dire c'est pas parce qu'ils ont gagné la
première manche qu'il gagneront la
partie et c'est aussi ce que je veux
dire dans ce livre moi j'appelle la
France Les Français au sursaut parce que
je suis convaincu que ils ne sont qu'une
toute petite minorité ces ennemis de la
République et qu'on est capable collec
et sereinement parce qu'il suffit d'être
courageux et ferme pour mettre fin à
leurs agissements c'est pas désespéré je
dis sauver notre pays on pourrait
continuer encore longtemps on a plus le
temps on s'arrête là les deux Frances
d'ailleurs le mot d'intégration qu'on
entend peu à droite pour vous n'est pas
tabou et vous et vous l'utilisez
peut-être qu'il faut voilà le porter
davantage pour compter sur moi voilà
réparer ce ce pays les de France et chez
Albin Michel vous restez avec moi
Vincent jeambrin c'est l'heure des
parties pris nos affranchis ils vont
vous faire réagir on les accueille tout
de suite
Thomas nestavel pour l'économie Isabelle
laasser du Figaro pour l'international
installez-vous je vous en prie on
commence par Bourbon Express comme
chaque soir l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nationale nous est raconté
ce soir par Elsa mondingava bonsoir à
vous Elsa bonsoir je reviens sur un un
rendez-vous très important pour nous à
l'Assemblée la séance de question
gouvernement je devrais plutôt dire les
séances de question gouvernement puisque
depuis le 21 novembre c'était une
expérimentation on est passé à deux
séances hebdomadaires en fait on est
revenu à ce qui se passait avant la
réforme de Richard Ferrand on est passé
je vous le rappelle à une séance de 2h
environ qui avait lieu tous les mardis à
une séance le mardi de 15h à 16h15 et
puis une autre le mercredi qui dure 45
minutes cette formule ça a été décidé ce
matin est prolonger au moins jusqu'au
mois de juin c'est la majorité des
groupes qui s'est prononcé pour les
questions au Gouvernement c'est mieux
une fois par semaine ou deux fois par
semaine deux fois par semaine parce
qu'on doit couvrir les actualités donc
deux fois par semaine c'est bien
effectivement ça doit changer un petit
peu notre rythme mais déjà d' avoir
proposé cette expérimentation et donc
cette prolongation je trouve que c'est
bien de jours par semaine on a
suffisamment d'actualité pour pouvoir
les couvrir le mardi et le mercredi deux
fois par semaine sans problème et en
réalité le Conseil des ministres a lieu
le mercredi matin si on veut des
informations fraîches récentes et
interroger le gouvernement c'est après
le conseil des ministres donc la séance
du mardi c'est sur la semaine qui vient
de s'écouler et le mercredi après-midi
c'est sur les questions qui ont été
abordées au Conseil des ministres donc
ça c'était donc la catégorie des pour et
puis comme chaque fois dans les sondages
il y a ce nspp ne se prononce pas c'est
le cas de Paul mollac alors c'est vrai
que quand ça dure 2h et qu4 c'est un peu
long et la deuxème heure on voit qu'il y
a moins de monde mais le mercredi la 2è
heure il y a moins de monde aussi donc
je sais pas je trouve ça peut-être moins
long effectivement
mais ne se prononce pas
quoi disons que c'est c'est pas le sujet
du siècle quoi merci beaucoup c'est
quand même le sujet de notre chronique
tant pis alors Paul mollac il a raison
pas quand il critique l'intérêt de cette
chronique he non quand tu dit qu'il y a
pas franchement énormément de monde le
mercredi regardez ces images c'était
tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle au début
c'est très clair semé j'ai compté à peu
près une centaine de députés peu de
présidents de groupe alors il y en a qui
sont arrivés en cours de route mais
c'est vrai qu'on peut dire à tout le
moins que les députés n'ont pas encore
vraiment pris en main ce nouveau
rendez-vous mais alors ce que les
oppositions dénonc c'est pas forcément
les horaires c'est que les les ministres
réond pas exactement c'est un argument
qu'on entend beaucoup dans la bouche des
oppositions écoutez Sébastien Jumel on
garde deux séances de questions au
gouvernement par semaine pour vous c'est
mieux qu'avant c'est moins pire que si
c'était mieux les question gouvernement
c'est le seul espace que nous avons pour
interpeller le gouvernement contrôler le
gouvernement est ce que nous sommes dit
en groupe communiste mardi c'est qu'il
fallait veiller à ce que le gouvernement
réponde réellement aux questions posées
et soit pas dans la posture et qu'il euh
consolide cet espace de question au
gouvernement en répondant sérieusement
aux interpellations des députés mais
comme me confia un député Miriam la
promesse est dans le nom du spectacle ça
s'appelle bien question au gouvernement
ça s'appelle pas réponse au députés oui
merci beaucoup d'un mot gamin à la les
rose vous les regardiez les cagues les
fameuses questions gouvernement mais oui
al peut-être pas gamin gamin mais lycéen
je je le regardais régulièrement ou bon
très bienus bon point pour LCP allez on
enchaîne avec vous Thomas Lestavel après
Orpa Altis SFR et Casino encore un
fluron de l'économie française dans la
tourmente effectivement alors ces
jours-ci c'est le groupe AtoS qui lutte
pour sa survie je sais pas si vous
connaissez le groupe AtoS oui enfit mal
enfin je gros groupe informatique c'est
ça un grand groupe informatique qui est
pas très connu du grand public
effectivement mais qui est d'une très
grande taille 11 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et près de 110000
salariés c'est pour vous donner un ordre
de grandeur plus que d'Anon ou L'Oréal
et surtout il est positionné sur des
activités très stratégiques dans des
domaines ultra sensibles en en France
par exemple aos gère des systèmes
sécurisés pour l'armée de l'air pour les
forces navales les forces sous-marines
et certaines centrales nucléaires donc
des des actifs vraiment stratégique elle
développe aussi des logiciels de gestion
pour des services d'intérêt national
comme Linky dans l'électricité ou la
SNCF et c'est aussi un spécialiste de la
cybersécurité qui est d'ailleurs en
charge de la cybersécurité des Jos de
Paris dans quelques mois alors pourquoi
Atos va mal qu'est-ce qui se passe alors
euh le Atos va mal et c'est pas c'est
pas tout récent et quand on regarde le
cours de bourse on voit que ça date de
plusieurs années mais on va dire que les
difficultés se sont accélérées en 2021
Athos a dépensé beaucoup trop d'argent
en s'endettant pour racheter des boîtes
qui étaient soit trop chè soit pas assez
performante soit les deux donc la
situation financière s'est dégradée par
ailleurs il y a eu le tournant du Cloud
Computing que Athos n'a pas pris
contrairement à ses concurrents et qui
étaiit pourtant très lucratif et puis
enfin il y a cette tendance à
délocaliser la main d'œuvre dans des
pays comme l'Inde qui a permis aux
concurrents justement comme cap géini de
réduire leur base de coût et Atos ne l'a
pas fait est devenu beaucoup moins
compétitif résult résultat aujourd'hui
le groupe a une dette de près de 5
milliards d'euros à gérer et il a dû
faire appel cette semaine à un
mandataire donc une tierce personne pour
gérer les négociations avec les 22
banques à qui elle doit de l'argent et
on lit déjà qu'il y a des fonds vautours
qui tournent autour du dossier à qui la
faute qui sont les responsables alors en
fait les les difficultés dont on parle
elles datent surtout de la décennie
précédente et en fait de 2009 à 2019
c'était Thierry Breton qui était
auparavant ministre de l'économie qui
était au manettees et ça fait partie de
ces dirigeants qui vient du du service
public de la haute dans le haut service
public
qui voilà exactement qui arrive aux
manettes et qui ont un peu la folie des
grandeurs ont un peu l'impression de
savoir mieux que les autres et peuvent à
terme démolir une société on a vu ça
avec Anne lvergeon pour Areva ou je pour
le crédilonnais donc c'est lié à ce ce
passage un peu de désastreux avec des
des décisions qui étaient pas les bonnes
et puis un autre coupable qui est là
aujourd'hui c'est le gouvernement actuel
qui en en fait à tardé à se saisir de ce
dossier ou c'est-à-dire comment
c'està-dire qu'en fait euh d'unot ouais
en fait les difficultés de datos se
dégradent depuis 3 ans et il y a une
sorte de silence assourdissant de la
part du gouvernement Bruno Le Maire a
dit cette semaine qu'il allait ne pas
laisser disparaître des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois mais ça arrive très
tard et vu le profil très stratégique de
l'entreprise quand on parle de
souveraineté dans les domaines
stratégiques c'est vrai que la
cybersécurité ou l'armée c'est c'est pas
rien et on peut s'étonner que ni
l'exécutif ni l'inspection générale des
finances ni même une commission
parlementaire né sonner l'alerte
convoquer la direction et demander des
comptes donc un peu comme pour Areva et
crédiloné on a un peu l'impression de de
laisser couler une boîte sans réagir
donc Emmanuel Macron qui parle de d'État
stratège d'État souverain charge à lui
de faire en sorte qu'un tel naufrage ne
se reproduise pas on suivra le dossier
grâce à vous merci beauoup Thomas on
termine avec vous moi cette histoire
elle me passionne elle est édifiante
vous nous dites que les États-Unis sont
en train de de lâcher définitivement
l'Ukraine écoutez définitivement pas
encore mais la tendance est extrêmement
négative ce qui s'est passé c'est que
Joe Biden depuis des mois essae de
convaincre les éliers républicains de
débloquer cette fameuse enveloppe de 60
milliards de dollars pour l'Ukraine et
il a accepté de la lier en fait à l'aide
à Israël et surtout au durcissement de
la politique migratoire américaine à la
frontière avec le Mexique les
républicains avaient fini par dire oui
on va la voter et il a suffi d'un tweet
d'une déclaration de Trump p en disant
ne votez pas cette loi SAR sacrilège
pour qu'il reviennent sur leurs
promesses on verra ce qui se passe
demain on voit deux choses que d'abord
le parti républicain est complètement
affilié à Donald Trump et que l'Ukraine
est le dernier décadé de souci Donald
Trump les conséquences pour l'Ukraine
vaelle la ch conséqu c'est un risque de
une risque de défaite militaire pour les
ukrainien si l' américain américaine
s'arrête la
symétrie militaire est de plus en plus
visible c'est-à-dire que d'un côté la
Russie a une grosse masse de réserves
humaines et elle a vraiment mis son pays
en économie de guerre elle a relancé la
production et les armes arrivent tous
les jours sur le front et de l'autre
côté les Ukrainiens manquent de
ressources humaines ils sont une
démocratie ils ne peuvent pas décréter
comme ça une mobilisation générale et le
rythme des armes occidentales c'est
vraiment tari or si les États-Unis
limite ou arrête leur aide militaire à
l'Ukraine l'Europe aujourd'hui n'a pas
encore trouvé la volonté politique de
remplacer les États-Unis h est-ce que
les jeux sont faits les jeux ne sont pas
faits l'Europe peut se réveiller parce
que sinon si elle ne le fait pas elle
prend le risque de
sortir de
l'histoire les
républicains peuvent
réfléchir Trump peut perdre au mois de
novembre mais les prévisions sont quand
même assez N négatif parce que chaque
semaine qui passe avec cette guerre au
Proche Orient consolide l'avance de
Donald Trump à la à la présidentielle et
chaque gaff et chaque absence de Joe
Biden qui est quand même très très âgé
nourrit en fait le vote Donald Donald
Trump alors Vladimir Poutine lui
n'attend que ça les élections du mois de
novembre et la victoire de Donald Trump
et aujourd'hui il a décidé de donnner un
coup de pouce à Donald Trump en
accordant une interview la première un
journ journaliste étranger depuis le
début de la Guer alors Tucker Carlson
ancien de Fox News viré de Fox News
parce qu'il était trop trumpiste
épousant totalement les thèses de Trump
et celle de Vladimir Poutine c'est lui
qui a une interview donc on voit que à
la fois Donald Trump et Vladimir Poutine
lutte pour la même campagne électorale
au mois de novembre ouis les liaisons
dangereuses Trump Poutine elles sont
elles sont effrayante et c'est
l'alliance des dictateurs contre les
démocraties et je crois que personne ne
peut laisser tomber le soldat Ukraine il
faut qu'on soit au côté du peuple
ukrainien il faut qu'on soit au côté des
démocraties et donc il y a un impératif
qui s'ouvre devant nous h c'est notre
guerre en fait vous nous dites je crois
que c'est notre guerre moi je j'ai un
membre de ma famille qui qui bénévole
dans une ONG là-bas en Ukraine et qui
nous dit on laisse mourir des gens de de
faim de de de détresse et surtout ça ne
tiendra pas si on vient pas au rfort il
faut trouver que la France en fait
assez je pense que collectivement parce
que ça va au-delà de la France l'Europe
et les démocraties devraent en faire
plus d'accord avec ça j'imagine Isabelle
laass ah ben je pense que c'est notre
guerre et je pense que l'avenir de
l'Occident et l'avenir d'Europe dépend
aujourd'hui du destin de l'Ukraine et le
destin de l'Ukraine se joue à Washington
et dans les capitales européennes merci
beaucoup merci les affranchis pour vos
parties prix et merci à vous
elsamondingava à très vite merci enfin
Vinent jeambbrin d'avoir été notre grand
témoin 1 heure en direct sur LCP les
deux Frances c'est à lire chez chez
Albin Michel je le disais le tableau est
sombre mais pas désespéré quelque chose
me dit que voilà vous avez un destin au
sein de la droite qui peut cheminer on
sait pas jusqu'où on verra ça compte
c'est que la France c'est un destin
merci à vous allez c'est à présent lors
de votre soirée documentaire Jean-Pierre
gracien très belle soirée à vous et à
demain même lieu même
[Musique]
heure
he